JONATAN SHAYA: My mom actually
told me about this new project
that she heard from
a friend of hers.
So I went to my computer, and I
started writing an application.
EMIL BOSTROM: It's
almost like a dorm,
but the people aren't young.
They're old.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKI MIELONEN: In
Finnish culture,
young people all pretty much
move out when they are 18.
But now, they are not going
to get their independence,
because they don't have money
to move out in Helsinki if they
want to live here.
The prices are very, very high.
Our project is called
A Home That Fits.
This is one solution, for youth
homeless problem in Helsinki.
EMIL BOSTROM: The application
process was quite long,
because there was, I think, a
little bit over 300 applicants.
I was really ecstatic, because
basically, I was homeless.
Not on the street, but homeless.
[SPEAKING FINNISH]
JONATAN SHAYA: In
a normal apartment,
it's like the neighbors
don't exactly talk to you.
Because Finnish people are--
I don't know-- kind of shy.
Here, they were very welcoming.
I had this really
heartwarming feeling
that it's good to be here.
I went to my neighbor.
I was actually baking
some sweet buns.
So I baked for her.
And she was like, oh, welcome.
Come in.
And we talked, and
we drank coffee.
[SPEAKING FINNISH]
EMIL BOSTROM: The gap between
young people and the old
isn't that big that
we can't be friends
and can't interact
and get along.
So I guess in the
bigger picture,
we can show the
rest of the world,
and especially Finland,
that this is a good thing,
and it's worth investing in,
and that both young people
and old people can benefit
from something like this.
NARRATOR: Please check
out this next video.
MAN: We were sort of like, well,
we pulled off this weird trick.
How many other
places could we get
into if we started doing this?
It's very enjoyable to
appreciate the world around you
and to have the
opportunity to do so.
NARRATOR: Thanks
for watching, and be
sure to subscribe
to "Seeker Stories."